in fact the students should be
encouraged to search for whatever
they're interested in and the teacher
should help that person find that
information hi there steve kaufman here
can
critical thinking
be taught
and how does that relate to language
learning
so
remember by the way if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications
those of you who follow my videos know
that i'm a great believer in listening
and reading
i believe that the language has to come
into us from outside we have to listen
and read and acquire words before we can
start speaking
at some point we have to start speaking
at some point we have to speak a lot
uh when we do start speaking obviously
we want to work on improving
our ability to speak our accuracy and
the use of words
our pronunciation and so forth but we
first have to get the language
into us
well i think much the same is true when
it comes to
our ability to
reason
okay and i have been on
what's known as list serves in other
words email communities with teachers
and very often teachers are very
interested in the subject of teaching
critical thinking or what they call
higher order thinking
i have always been very suspicious
of the ability of the average teacher to
teach
critical thinking skills or higher order
if in fact such a thing exists the
thinking skills the assumption there is
that their students
have a lower order thinking because
these are
teachers of english
and so rather than focusing in on
how do i get my students to read more
how do i get my students to listen more
how do i provide them with content of
interest things that are relevant to
them things that they're familiar with
that they're going to want to engage
with how do i stimulate them how do i
get create that that thirst for reading
and listening
rather
there is this sort of
what i call a myth that they can teach a
set of skills that will enable their
in this case these were english teachers
teaching
you know english as a second language
that these
foreigners
might be
immigrant from
iran or from poland or from nicaragua
but somehow because they didn't speak
english well somehow they're
critical thinking skills weren't uh
as developed as as as the skills of the
teacher
i have always felt
that
the most important sort of
prerequisite
for
critical thinking
is knowledge of the subject matter you
cannot judge
because part of this whole critical
thinking is that
people need to be better equipped to uh
you know
judge uh
what's true or not true in the media
and and so forth which is all fine and
dandy we should be
uh
a little uh skeptical about what we read
and then we should be trying to read
through and see what we agree and what
we don't agree with
however
in most cases
the positions that we hold are based on
our emotions we jump to a conclusion and
then we try to justify that conclusion i
do that everyone does that if we didn't
all do that we'd all arrive at the same
conclusion because we would follow some
rational method of critical thinking and
you know objectively evaluate all the
information and we'd arrive at the only
correct uh conclusion but there is no
only correct conclusion there's lots of
different conclusions but generally
speaking the more knowledgeable a person
is about a particular subject the more i
value their opinion i don't think you
can
somehow skip the stage of just as in
language learning acquiring words and
phrases you can't speak before you have
a lot of words and phrases in you until
you have good comprehension you're not
going to speak well well until you have
read a lot on a subject or experienced
that situation acquired a lot of
information and knowledge and experience
about that subject your opinion is
perhaps not that important and there's
no amount of theoretical you know
critical thinking skills that are going
to substitute for
solid
knowledge of the subject matter and the
way to get
knowledge of the subject matter is to
read a lot to read well and so
rather than
with these esl teachers trying to teach
critical thinking
if you encourage those learners to read
a lot to read widely initially to read
on subjects of interest to them
they will find
different sources of information because
the chances are the teacher who's
teaching critical thinking wants to sort
of direct the learner in a certain
direction so that the learner will come
to the same conclusion as the teacher
and so that this whole teaching of
critical thinking in effect becomes a
way of controlling what the learner
thinks
and i think there's already too much
control
by teachers in other words
this is the book you're supposed to read
this is the newspaper you should read
this is a subject matter you should read
is sort of the teacher directing the
student in fact the student should be
encouraged to search for whatever
they're interested in and the teacher
should help that person find that
information just as i'm dealing doing
with sahara i tell her what i'm
interested in i'm interested in history
so she gives me this wonderful series on
persian history
this again stimulates me to not only
read on in persian which i'm limited in
my ability to do but also to look up
books in english on
iranian history
and so i'm constantly through reading
i'm acquiring more information not
with a goal that i'm going to think
critically but obviously if i read a
book on
iranian history and then i read a book
on turkish history and and and arabic
history and written by different people
or when i was doing uh ukrainian and
polish and russian then i would listen
to
you know
a russian version of ukrainian history a
polish version a ukrainian version and
out of all of these different bits of
information
based to some extent on my
you know
conclusions that i arrived at because of
say a degree of sympathy for the
ukrainians underdogs uh but someone else
who is more sympathetic to the polls or
to the russians might find that the
polish or russian version is
is closer to the truth
uh but i don't think it's any particular
critical thinking skill that's going to
take us to those conclusions it's more a
mindset that we have we've arrived at
for whatever emotional
obey whatever emotion based reason of
course we use reason to try and justify
our position and hopefully we're
open-minded enough to listen to other
people present
you know the justification for their
position using reason but ultimately i
think i mean it's very difficult to
persuade people uh to give up a point of
view that they have that's been my
experience uh it can be interesting and
if we're open-minded enough to accept
the pap the fact that people can have
different points of view and that
doesn't necessarily make them a bad
person that doesn't mean that i have to
agree with them
because i ask for their opinion
they don't have to agree with me
we can just share our views and continue
to disagree and that's fine and dandy
but uh
i i say this because so often
i think that teachers are prone to
pursue certain fads like teaching
critical thinking higher order thinking
or this learning styles myth which has
been largely debunked by which a whole
bunch of teachers pursued that you know
are you a kinetic learner are you a
visual learner and of course
cognitive scientists
assure us and all kinds of tests have
demonstrated this is not the case that
the learning styles is
is a bit of a
a bit of a red herring so i just thought
i'd mention that my view on this whole
subject of critical thinking
uh
it's possible that there are people who
are expert at critical thinking
who are you know methodical and follow
the scientific method and uh pursue a
variety of different sources of
information and then apply very uh you
know consistent uh uh
rational methods for arriving at their
conclusions i still suspect they're
gonna be you know
it'll be flavored by their
uh prejudice preconceived idea going in
but the people who can do that is a
small minority the vast majority of
people don't have those skills and
therefore the vast majority of teachers
are not in a position to teach those
skills and i don't really think those
skills exist
outside of what we call domain knowledge
knowledge about the subject matter and
to get that good knowledge of the
subject matter you have to read a lot so
the focus should be on getting students
to read more anyway that's just a bit of
a rant there off my normal subject yet
related because as with language
learning it's input that helps us grow
whether in language or in discovering
more about the world
thank you for listening
bye for now